a lot of women talk about kind of this
single season and taking time for
themselves it's never any kind of
improvement that benefits the future
partner no for me it is yeah they're
never like it's never like I'm training
I'm trying to develop qualities that my
mind was like I'm trying to be the kind
of woman it's always like I'm just
letting myself be me you know because
maybe it's something nice
Carousel bro let's call it how it is
true you know going through this thing
in a season like bro it's just a bunch
of things
be about your mind why should
self-healing be about another person
itself
from what she's 21 years old no
the point of this healing I would
imagine is to become a healthy person
then have a healthy relationship right
yeah but that healthy relationship needs
another person so when you're healing
yourself you're also trying to develop
the quality of feminine that the person
would like see men understand this right
we don't go to the gym and just decide
I'm just gonna be some gym dude now I
want to do better my job I want to have
a better fashion sense I want to work
and always I want to work on my anger
management might not understand this but
I never hear women talk about like the
difficult things to me I Define it as
things that I actually take work like
when you talk about the men you want I
never hear about things that take work
like I'm gonna have to learn how to have
a conversation I'm gonna have to learn
how to support him in a way that still
respects him I never hear about the
difficult things always what comes
naturally it's always accept who you are
whatever you are all the time and wait
for the world to come to my doorstep no
it's true because even in my last
delicious I was realizing I was the one
always making the decisions or like in
like literally all my past relationship
well not much but yeah so I was really I
was the one making decisions and that's
more of like a masculine trait yeah so
what I had to realize was how to have a
conversation in a way that was more
feminine like what you were saying
earlier like if the man was to come of
his problems instead of me saying okay
cool I'm the one that has to fix it and
think oh what's the answer to his
problem more like you know what you got
this like I know you can do it like I
believe in you you can do that and
letting him come up with the answer and
be the man so I'm kind of working on
things like that a bit more on like my
replies and stuff because my automatic
response would be let me heal this man
so I need to get out of that before
getting into another relationship can I
ask you a question yeah have you
considered that finding a man that does
not bring his problems to you and solves
them for himself might be the best life
for you no 100 but I mean if he does
come to me about a problem like he's not
coming to me to fix it he's just saying
oh this happened not a thing where it's
like oh this happened what do I do but
in fact this happened but it's like as
his woman he's just knowing he's just
venting he's just saying it but I'm my
response should be you know what you got
this that is fine but it's like if he
knows that from past experiences that
the woman is gonna be fixed he's
probably fixes problem and he's gonna
feel pity for um like she's gonna feel
pity for him she's gonna Wanna Stop but
if she if he knows that I as a woman I'm
not going to feel pity for him he will
feel comfortable to like say it I have a
question do you want to be married
yeah I do do you feel like you were
raised to be a wife
um
no in my household no like I was born in
a household with my mom and my dad but
um and they're married and everything
but I spent more time with my dad so
that's why I feel like I've almost as
like such an independent woman like boss
lady in all my relationships I'll be
paying for things because I was more
with my dad than I was look up to him
and be like oh
um I would look at him as my role model
so I'll be like you know I'll pay for
the dates whatever but
um I'm trying to come out of that like
that's part of my healing stage I'm
trying to uh follow-up question yeah
would you be willing and accepting if a
strong man came into your life and
helped build you into a wife I'm not
ready yet that's why I mean no no no I'm
saying I'm yeah I hear you're saying
is if he came into your life would you
be accepting of him building you into
the wife that he wanted yeah I
definitely will be like that is what I
feel like this healing is for for that
so I'm ready for that
who on the panel wants to be married
um
the panel feels like they're raised to
be a wife
I think it depends on the war was
definitely raised to BR how because
especially with my culture I'm South
American like which country I'm South
American Brazilian all right yeah so I
feel like in my culture there's two
sides there's obviously that the side
that everyone talks about that's not
very good and all of this bad stuff but
then on the other hand I've actually
been raised in Brazil and I've actually
grown up in a strict like Catholic
household my mum's always taught me how
to be a wife like from a young age she
would tell me like oh this is what not
really exactly what you have to do but
this is what I mean you have to show
yeah like the traits that a man would
like like cooking cleaning being
supportive yes yeah bring other women
home okay I never agree with but that's
just my personal choice like obviously
in the broader picture I do see men
bringing other women home but in my
personal choice that was something that
that's something I could never run so I
I have a question for the women that
said
um that they want to be wives
um but they don't feel like they're
raised to be a wife do you guys have
married women around you no no I do no
no yeah I do
rub it in
um anyone yeah no you have okay
um have you guys ever sought to like
seek that out
what in what scent what do you mean
because you you want to be married right
that's the outcome you want so how would
you learn how to be married
you would look to people that are
married yeah yeah yeah yeah
most of the time but yeah like for all
of this I don't think about that I don't
really look back at my past
to I don't know to move forward I just
know what I want for myself and I know
that no but I mean if I wanted to be a
pro Vault like I played volleyball right
I was offered a pro contract in the fall
and what did I do to become a pro
volleyball player yeah almost right a
YouTube thing took off but I had to get
coaches yeah yeah to teach me how to
play yeah yeah no I agree with that and
I think that's a problem with um society
today we don't
I don't know I think people like Kevin
Samuels but he was important because
especially for me he made me
think about what the type of guys I want
would want from me I never thought about
that before I started listening to him
you know he was the first person to say
hey like it's all good think about what
you want as a woman but what about
thinking about what the type of guys you
want would want from you how do you how
do you learn how do you go about
learning what they want and then
bringing that to the table and I think
that's the problem with
with society today it's all about yeah
it's all about well this is how I am and
you know I need to find someone who can
who can match that but I definitely am
somebody that thinks about what you know
the type of husband I would want would
want from me I I um and I acknowledge
that I don't know everything you know
which is why I don't know when people
are talking I'm very quiet I'm like I'm
the type of person where it's like I'm I
want to learn I want to learn yeah what
do you consult what what is your source
of information or whether you where do
you kind of get your knowledge not that
book
I haven't read that book actually I
don't know
um I think
um I don't know it's just it's just
listening to conversations like this
Kevin Samuels for me was somebody that
really like got me interested in
thinking about this sort of stuff I
don't know I don't know I guess yeah
well there's a huge space online of
self-improvement for men because men
generally recognize you know if the guy
is sitting there and he's not getting
you know the dating life he wants he's
not having the relationships he wants he
recognizes well okay I need to do
something about this the onus is on me
and so then you know they go to the
internet and they find people who are
talking about you know making money or
or going to the gym or you know all of
these different things it's all about
self-improvement I think there's less of
that for women because I mean there is
there is some
um but there's less of it for women
because like surgery yeah plastic
surgery because women are mainly you
know there's a there's a sense in the
culture that women are enough you know
we're so we're I'm enough you know
um that gets said very often doesn't it
and and because women are sort of
pedestalized in mainstream Society the
woman is encouraged to think oh I'm a
princess anyway I'm so I'm I'm
somebody's Queen anyway so I don't need
to do anything and actually really what
we should all be doing is looking at how
we can improve right because I knew that
yeah go on do you want to talk no I was
just gonna say like for me I obviously
I'd love to be married like in the
future I don't think you know I I don't
know a girl that wouldn't want to be in
a happy marriage and this like that but
I wasn't raised by oh I was raised in
the single parent household like my mom
raised me and my brother and she's not
married she never got married to my dad
and I couldn't ask for anything more
like I think I have I took some of the
best morals from her and my grandma
likes really really strong influential
women in my life and I would take those
things that I learned from them into my
into my future marriage and then
anything added is about learning and
picking up from other people that are
also influential in your life you know
whether I'd be friends family who you
see on social media who you see just
around I that's what I think so anyway
are you saying you don't think you
should seek out married women for advice
or you do I'm just I'm confused no no
like I think it does help but like I'm
just saying it the the process is just
about learning if you haven't had that
you know you know what you know what
this sounds like to me right it sounds
like when you ask a student whether
they've done extra reading on the topic
and they're like you know I saw
something
I think like Tim was talking about some
of the corridor I think you have to
actively look to understand the divine
feminine and and the role of a woman and
a wife and how that can compliment a man
I think it sounds like it's very it
sounds like you're not doing that but if
you want to be honest with yourself to
say am I looking out like am I seeking
out that information and really trying
to I'll tell you how a man does it right
I've read three or four books on how to
engage with women because when I was
younger I couldn't I couldn't get down
texting game I had me and my one of my
closest friends in uni our whole
relationship is based on us me learning
how to text now text people get no
response and he would dissect the text
and be like you said too much here this
could have been a simple sentence it was
a compound sentence you kind of gave the
impression that you're asking for
permission here and I eventually figured
it out I read The Art of Seduction I
read bang volume one two I read all
these books to try and understand women
and I feel like you need to do a similar
thing to understand what the man you
want to high level man would want from a
woman yeah but the problem is Alex when
we're sold these books like why men love
to understand men or the movie
Hitch it's it's like what what quality
book is there to understand men the beam
is Led even hitch hitch doesn't even
make sense so he's this Suave guy he
meets a woman who's like got basic
levels of confidence falls in love with
her and then gives up his whole life on
stability to chase her it's a it's a
movie about ego it's it's what these
women like uh these women that baby trap
athletes think are like oh I'm gonna
change him and then he's gonna like drop
everything and that that's the real
message it's not saying I had to change
I had to meet him halfway I had to help
him feel safe that's that's not what
it's saying it's saying you're so cute
that top man will eventually fall for
you for no reason because you're good
enough I I do still think it is a whole
process like I'm like the youngest
person in this room I'm 20 you know I'm
not looking to get married next year
like the whole thing is just a journey
and it's growth and it's about personal
growth and you know the answer the
answer no
you know what I mean but I'm just saying
but it's like you give this like word
salad instead of just no no but from
someone who doesn't hasn't had that
growing up being in a married household
I'm com I'm happy with what I got you
know I'm I can sit and be comfortable
with that when do you want to be married
by I don't know I don't have a I don't
have it doesn't so 45
okay so you you do have a rough okay so
yeah I'd say so I think okay so you want
to be married by 35. yeah I'd say that
was right well I'm not putting like why
is that mad do you want kids because it
clearly it sounds like there's no woman
around you who are saying listen you're
young you're gorgeous this is the time
you set the foundations for who you want
to be it sounds like they're saying just
chill trust me when women get past a
certain age the poor reduces
significantly no absolutely not I
disagree with that like my my mum is so
like you and cross my mum like she's so
strong and I think whether that's to do
with her job or just the fact that my
grandma was also a single parent whether
that's to do hold your mom she is 51.
and she has a job yeah and she has
failed as you will
sorry straight up your mom's lying to
you you want to get married at 35. he's
at risk you wanna have children no I
never said I'd get married at 35 pill
was giving me an estimate you said you
said you said yes no she said 45 and I
said No and then she said 35 and you
said yes that's about right yeah yeah
too late too late I'll marry a 20 year
old instead that's fine right look I'm
just telling you like box wine cats
that's your life no I just I don't know
go to the club
how old is she how old are you I'm 37.
are you married huh are you saying
single what do you like to know well I'm
just saying like but I'm not the one
with the problem you're not the same
though you're not delusional you're not
this and I hate that for you because
you're a pretty girl that's really smart
and I hate that you're saying these
things because you could probably be a
hell of a good wife and a good mother
you're not a stupid woman I think you're
misled It's just sad to see you're
married on your 37 years have you been
married divorced have you got kids
listen let me just say this I have it
all I got it all
I'm almost stressing to you like I don't
want to be mean to you almost stressing
to you that this is like it's the wrong
path like waiting that late tell me that
it's a wrong path because it's your path
right have you got your life together
that's funny that a sex worker is going
to ask Listen Here Lady look my dear
yeah I have my life completely together
there's nothing in my life I would
change in any way
why you're being angry now because I'm
trying because
you're angry about your life my dear
okay
I have a question do you do you think
no I I really because I don't want to be
mean to you or anybody and I apologize
if I have I just simply think that wait
until 35 to get married and finding
yourself and sleeping with a bunch of
people it's gonna be bad no one said we
were waiting to think you literally just
said that like what is so right about
your path that makes mine wrong no it's
not me comparing myself to you it's just
me saying damn that's gonna not be good
because I see it all the time it's not
because I'm not trying to pick on you I
just see these girls they're on
Instagram they got their boobs out and
they're doing all this stuff and you're
lagging them as well at the same time
like that that's that's irrelevant right
yeah
what does that matter what are you
saying well he shouldn't be talking like
that then what are you saying true or
not
just listen like listen to what he's
saying he actually he actually had he uh
and I've agreed with them but almost
half of the stuff he's been saying but
I'm saying just listen before you get
triggered listen I'm just simply saying
that likely you're going to want to have
kids in a family long before 35. that's
all I'm saying for sure that's what I'm
saying and in addition and I don't mean
to cut you off I'm sorry you're going to
want a real man not a man that's going
to come home and cry to you not a man
that you have to mother that would just
make you a broken bird you want a guy
that you can look up to and you want to
be the like the leader in your
relationship yeah absolutely but
then the suggestion of like well I'm not
going to learn any of these skills
because I'm only 20. I think I think the
general point is like if you go to other
countries if you know Ukraine before the
the current war and you know Russia I
mean there are women there getting
married at like 22 23. oh yeah no no you
know it's it's societally here we've got
this different idea about it you know
but it's not it's not worldwide yeah as
many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider sending a super
thanks below every donation helps and it
helps make what we do possible